I think it's pretty clear that President
Donald Trump is going to announce
probably within the next week it'll give
him a chance and all the rest of us a
chance to see what happens
if he catches fire again it probably
makes people like DeSantis and others
think twice about running if it's
lukewarm or not good at all maybe it
opens the field not just the DeSantis
but Abbott Christine gnome Nikki Haley
Mike Pompeo Mike Pence Ted Cruz you name
it the whole universe out there
speaking of shifts I don't know if
you've seen any of this but a lot of
people are saying that you know gen Z
which is now voting for the first time
that they're all coming in and in
essence you know they're they're sort of
default leftists they've been taught
that socialism is cool that big
government is good you should just be
given stuff and all this it's obviously
counter to the work that you guys do and
I've spoke at many young Americas events
and people are excited about freedom and
all that but but it is an uphill battle
for sure
oh it totally is because it's starting
younger and younger I mean we just took
over in addition to the Reagan Ranch out
in California this last year we took
over the Reagan boy at home in the
middle of the country in Dixon Illinois
where we have conferences but we also
occasionally have tours and school
groups that come through our director
recently told me that some fifth grade
students that were there with a class
trip loved the tour but at one point our
director was talking about how Reagan
and his actions as we just recognized
this past week you know November 9th the
33rd anniversary of the the Berlin Wall
coming down the fall communism he's
talking about communism and the kids
said well what's wrong with Communism
and the guy was like Bill Wilder and
he's like you know we're taught that
that's a system of government that helps
people like no this is not it at all uh
but it's sadly what we've seen for years
in college campuses we actually have a
suit against the administrators at
Clovis Community College in Fresno
California where during Freedom week
last year we had our chapter there had
posters that were approved pre-approved
to put up the posters showed a woman in
the old Soviet Union standing in a
grocery store where there was no fruit
on the shelves which sadly was pretty
frequent back then as it is in places
like Cuba and Venezuela today and it
said got milk got bread got blankets got
anything and it was obviously making a
point about communism and socialism not
working and the the administrators
literally took the posters down and
claimed the reason for that was because
it was offensive the Communist well hell
yeah it's offensive to Communists that's
because they're wrong it's the truth we
got to get the truth out and it's got to
happen sooner because the indoctrination
is happening younger and younger along
the way yeah I mean it's incredible that
that's leaking into Elementary School at
this point but I suppose at some level
none of this uh should surprise us going
back to a bit of the resource politics
for a moment uh you know the the big
thing in in Republican politics or in
conservative politics whatever you want
to call it is sort of this this Trump
DeSantis thing that seems to be be
bursting forth whether we like it or not
what's your take and what do you think
is going to happen
well I think that'll be interesting just
because of Ron DeSantis just having
elected he's obviously going to focus on
being governor in the short term someday
whether it's 2024 or 2028 at some point
I think you'll want to be an excellent
candidate but that may not be the worst
of all scenarios because I think it's
pretty clear that President Donald Trump
is going to announce probably within the
next week it'll give him a chance and
all the rest of us a chance to see what
happens
if he catches fire again it probably
makes people like DeSantis and others
think twice about running if it's
lukewarm or not good at all maybe it
opens the field not just the DeSantis
but Abbott Christian gnome Nikki Haley
Mike Pompeo Mike Pence Ted Cruz you name
it the whole universe out there and I
think you know as much as I don't talk
and tweet the way that Donald Trump does
I do think he's earned the right based
upon what he did during those four years
as president he is without a doubt
earned the right to be at least at the
top of the list of consideration doesn't
guarantee that he'll win the nomination
or be elected president but I think he's
at least earned it I was suspect early
on but my goodness I mean tax cuts
regular regulatory reform some of the
greatest judicial nominations I've ever
seen even simple things like doing what
nobody else had the guts to do and
moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem maybe there's a whole
cross-section of things that most of us
as conservatives even from the
libertarian's point of view never
dreamed were possible that this guy got
accomplished now does he always talk or
tweet or have the same tone that many of
us do probably not but again I I like
people who do more than just people who
talk and for that he earns a lot of
credit you mentioned I do think at the
flip side of it is he's yeah he's got a
little bit of a challenge though I think
because many of the people that he
endorsed in the primaries either didn't
win or like with Vance wouldn't have won
without the wine and so that'll be part
of the equation as well right and again
as we're taping this we still don't know
what's happening with Carrie Lake and
with Blake Masters and black salt so
some of this could shake out a little
bit better and but we'll kind of see but
since you mentioned the Libertarians
there on Twitter at least there's always
this war with the Libertarians you know
basically do we remain hardcore
Libertarians and only vote for
libertarian candidates or obviously
we're a bit closer to being Republicans
certainly the Democrats do we align
there uh again these are all the ideas
that Young Americans Foundation are
talking about all the time what do you
think sort of strategically for the for
the person that's out there that just
it's limited government it's lower no
taxes states rights that's it what do
you think they should be doing
well I think the simple answer is don't
ever let the perfect be the enemy of the
very good and by that I don't mean just
universally if you're a Libertarian vote
Republican but I do think don't limit
yourself to solely voting uh libertarian
because while that's great in principle
it doesn't get things done I think
Reagan certainly was a great person at
bringing different coalitions together I
hope during my eight years in office
three elections of which the recall was
one of the biggest in the nation we were
able to do that and we reigned in
government one of the biggest
frustrations to me I don't even remember
this but a few years ago Matt Bevin the
governor of the Commonwealth of Kentucky
arguably at the time the most
libertarian-like candidate in the
country a guy who aggressively cut red
tape who aggressively reigned in the
government who cut taxes who took on
these big issues in in Kentucky and he
lost that election just barely in the
margin by which he lost to Brashear the
current governor was less than the
margin of what the libertarian can today
for governor of God in that race and so
to me it's just a great reminder I get
it with some of these what some people
might call rhinos people who are like a
lot of government spending who are just
a little bit less bad than than the
Democrat running in the race but in that
case it was a prime example this is a
guy that Libertarians should love this
is a guy that Libertarians you want to
uh should want to replicate around the
country and yet they got behind a
candidate who effectively put set that
margin down and now you got a full-scale
big spending big government Democrat in
there it to me it just doesn't make a
lot of sense don't do it across the
board make those candidates those
Conservative Republican candidates earn
it and then hold them accountable when
they get in the office and I think
Libertarians can make some Royal inroads
that way let's talk about the the other
side of the coin here uh the
progressives have have basically just
taken over the Democrat Party and I
think unfortunately because of the
results that are kind of wishy-washy
this week I think they'll basically feel
emboldened
um do you think there's any stopping
that movement within the Democrat Party
may I say I would imagine I'm not
totally well versed in in Wisconsin
politics but I would imagine you've
probably got some moderate uh or had
some moderate uh Democrats in Wisconsin
back in the day but they they all seem
to be gone at a national level now
well even in the states I mean when I
was governor and certainly years before
a long time ago when I was briefly in
the state legislature but even a few
years ago when I was governor there were
still a few of the kind of traditional
Blue Dog outstate somewhat rural area
Democrats who uh were somewhat moderate
to conservative in some issues but you
know we're aligned with unions and other
things along the way they're gone
they're gone most of those districts
it's one of the unique phenomenas while
the suburbs moved away from Republicans
under President Trump more I think based
on tone than on policy flip side of that
is in a lot of those rural blue-collar
areas around my state and around the
country a lot of those Democrats who'd
held those seats before boy this wave
came in and good solid Republican
candidates won those seats so that shift
has certainly happened in Wisconsin but
I think arguably elsewhere in the
country and nationally uh yeah I mean I
think about this Joe Biden who ran just
a few years ago two and a half years ago
Joe Biden on super Tuesday was based
basically positioning himself as a more
mainstream alternative to Bernie Sanders
he eventually got mayor Pete and and
Senator Klobuchar out of his Lane the
mainstream more moderate Reign because
he knew he had all these other people
you had Bernie and and Elizabeth Warren
and others in the far left wing Lane But
the irony was he did that to win the
primary and then did the opposite of
what traditionally happens he then went
out in the general and ran hard to the
left to get burning an AOC support and
basically outsourced his agenda to them
remember Kamala Harris actually had a
voting record the year before she was
picked that was further to the left than
the the self-proclaimed socialist Bernie
Sanders and he hasn't stopped since if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Asian Bell